you know i actually wasn't planning to
do a holiday themed episode this year
except that saturday is my usual video
release day and saturday happens to fall
on christmas itself this year and
keeping that in mind i figured i really
have no business talking about anything
else
[Music]
happy holidays to you folks whether you
celebrate christmas or not whether you
celebrate something else whether you
celebrate nothing
best wishes to you
now i'm not going to do what i've done
in the past i am not going to be
examining a specific piece of holiday
themed media nor am i going to be doing
any kind of list like i did with the
doctor who specials the christmas
special at one point i thought about
bringing that back except then i
realized that the newer specials that
have come out since then have been new
years and not christmas so it actually
the list wouldn't have changed so
maybe i'll revisit that just see if the
order changed at some point but not this
year no instead i found myself thinking
on the subject of
christmas themed television episodes
now first thing i'm talking about
episodes of an already running tv show
not christmas specials
so get out of here with your
charlie brown and snoopy in the dinky
little tree that falls over
that's not what we're dealing with here
we're talking about special holiday
themed episodes of shows that aren't
just strictly there to do that they're
running the rest of the time of the year
and this is just a holiday themed
episode of a standard show now i am not
going to be giving you a list of the
best ones or any kind of ranking and i'm
definitely not going to try and make a
statement of what is the greatest
episode of christmas tv ever made
because that would require me to look up
and watch
an unbelievable amount of christmas
themed television episodes and there are
neither enough hours in the day nor
enough booze in my house to get me
through a project like that
however
when i found myself looking over lists
of christmas themed episodes
and in particular at lists that were
focused on what are generally thought to
be the best ones
i noticed some things
in there some patterns as i tend to do
and that struck me as something that i
do kind of want to talk about
now
i'm not
getting into any kind of deep analytical
statistical analysis here
what i did was i looked up how about a
half dozen or so lists of what are
supposedly the best uh christmas
episodes of television from various
sources now i didn't go through and
laboriously
calculate everything involved because
there was a lot of overlap there was
some times where
you know one
list would have an episode from a tv
show that that tv shows on another list
but they didn't pick the same episode
there's ones that just showed up on
almost every list etc etc etc
i was more interested in
what kind of shows are thought to have
the best christmas episodes now i am
going to give you some numbers these
numbers are only coming from the list of
100 that i found however i do want to
emphasize while i was not in the mood to
compile the data from all the other
lists into a master list i did make a
quick comparison in terms of rough
numbers to determine whether or not the
percentage of types of shows of this
type versus other types was similar
across all lists and it was the genre of
television that had the most was the was
the one that had the most entries in
each of these lists and so what i was
looking at was
genre
in the general sense genre has become a
little bit of a nebulous thing but i
broke it down into several
broad categories
out of the hundred i was looking at
sitcoms
children's animation adult animation
dramas and science fiction or fantasy
now there is a little bit of
bending on my part there are some shows
that are kind of comedy dramas but if
they were longer than a half hour i'm
like that's not really a sitcom there
were plenty of shows that i'd honestly
never heard of and i'm kind of leaning
on having looked up the show and looking
for what genre it's classified under
when it gets listed on things like
wikipedia imdb etc so i'm not an expert
on all these things and people might
disagree with some of my classifications
and like i said i've bent rules in a few
places like for example i put sesame
street under um children's cartoons even
though it's technically not a cartoon
and i put the simpsons under adult
animation even though it's not
considered adult these days especially
consider compared to things like south
park and family guy but that's still and
where i ended up putting it anyways
based on what i found out of that
hundred 64
were from episodes of sitcoms 15
came from dramas adult animation and
science fiction and fantasy had eight
apiece there were four children's
cartoons and there was one uh
colbert christmas because while
the colbert report was very much a
comedy show it also wasn't a sitcom so i
didn't know what to do with it there's
your random outlier but i did find that
uh that spread of data
uh unsurprising
but also kind of interesting it's always
interesting when you kind of quantify
something that you already suspect
because you know what in the back of my
head
i knew sitcoms were gonna have the most
on this list
now again nearly any tv show that
runs during and very close to the
holiday season is going to have at least
one
holiday usually christmas episode in its
run
that's always going to be what's
happened but the reason i zeroed in on
this list of best was because that seems
to give an indication of what type of
television
lends itself to celebrating the
christmas season well and undeniably it
does look like sitcoms have the easy
lead why is that
is it because
the holiday is laughable it's a joke
no
but christmas by its nature is
forgive me for saying it it's a little
bit silly
it's a little bit
wacky
what we do how we celebrate it whether
it be the things that the majority of us
do
like putting a dying tree in the middle
of our living room and then covering it
up with artificial lights and baubles or
whether it be the strange thing specific
to any individual families traditions
etc etc
so
there is a lot to play with
in terms of keeping with the tone of a
sitcom
sitcoms tend to be
lighter and like some of these
individual episodes were heavier
episodes but these shows in general tend
to be a little bit more buoyant a little
sillier they're not taking themselves
that seriously
and christmas really shouldn't be taken
that seriously i'm not saying your
traditions shouldn't be taken seriously
take them as seriously as you'd like but
i'm saying that it's supposed to be fun
and sitcoms
are also supposed to be fun so they
align almost perfectly
it is interesting to think about when it
shows up in other things though because
a christmas episode of a sitcom that's
kind of a no-brainer isn't it
it just suits things and most sitcoms
tend to be family-based and even the
ones that aren't are still based around
something that you can have a christmas
episode about a workplace sitcom can
center it around the christmas party
easy to do
but when you step outside of sitcoms and
start looking at other things you start
getting uh
something a little bit else
something a little bit different
there's the dramas which will often
center on
familial strife
sometimes as a combination of whatever
the heck's been going on in the show up
to that point or sometimes as a unique
situation if it's something more uh
procedural like house or boston legal or
what have you which
also makes sense it makes sense that
dramas came in second i mean it's a big
gap it's not close between sitcoms and
dramas but it does make sense that
dramas are second because as much as
christmas is meant
to be light
and breezy and fun
it's not always
and usually if it's not it's
because of things involved with
families and things that may or may not
be going well with families and drama
can dig into
that side of the holiday which while
less pleasant
doesn't necessarily ring any less true
now i'm not just going to go down the
order i'm actually going to kind of jump
to the bottom real quick
i was initially surprised at how few
children's cartoons or children's
programming were on this list
there were only four
but then i thought about it i'm like
you know
even in the better children's television
shows
the christmas episodes tend to be very
rote
they tend to just be
here's what my family's doing for
christmas
somebody's crisis about believing in
santa claus or they retell a christmas
carol
that's kind it
and given how formulaic they tend to be
and how formulaic children's television
is in general for gonna be completely
honest it's not that surprising that
very few stood out because i guarantee
you there is a monstrously long list
of episodes of kids shows with christmas
episodes
but they probably mostly suck
so that was sort of interesting to think
about oh by the way if you're wondering
if i have a grand or point i'm building
to i really don't
i'm just having fun
thinking about this so if you're waiting
for me to get to the point i actually
don't have one
i am not taking this all that seriously
either i'm taking the sitcom approach to
this whole thing
i felt like i should say that before you
before you sink any more time into this
with me
adult animation is a little bit of a
sort of a shotgun genre
it can be all over the place and by
adult animation it can be things
slightly more grounded or more seriously
flavored like your king of the hills
more often though it's gonna be your
south parks your family guys your
futuramas your more outlandish things
i find it interesting that at least from
the ones that i recognized
a lot of those were more
deconstructions
of christmas they were more about making
fun of the idea
or the traditions
or in just in general
taking the piss out of them
and not in a light oh these are our
traditions they're a little wacky way
but in
isn't this dumb sort of way
which
i mean if we're being completely honest
a lot of adult animation tends to be
very mean spirited which is a big part
of why i don't watch a lot of it
but then
then there's the one that you shouldn't
be surprised i kind of gravitated
towards thinking about
science fiction and fantasy
this is where you're gonna find well
your doctor who christmas specials for
one thing
but then in addition to that your
eurekas supernaturals buffy the vampire
slayer and the way that these kinds of
shows choose to chat to tackle christmas
again just judging by the ones that i
have in fact seen is a little bit
odd
it can be one of a couple things it can
be something that is basically stepping
out of the normal narrative of the story
to fully dive into
a christmas thing which is what doctor
who usually tended to do
it could be a more or less standard
episodes with some christmas trappings
which is a little bit what the buffy one
did i mean the themes run a little
deeper than that
but
it usually is not just playing it
straight because when you're dealing
with a sci-fi fantasy situation
well things are gonna get
a little
weird
and it's pretty common for these
to in some way involve
a supernatural christmas
thing whether it be
tied to
uh belief in christmas whether it be
like some weird twisted version of santa
claus whether it be some sort of holiday
ghost
not necessarily doing christmas carol
again though
doctor who did just straight up do
christmas carol again
they tend to take these weird sideways
angles at integrating christmas into
these things it's actually worth pausing
to stop and think about how these sorts
of things in general actually manifest
in any of these shows
because
the christmas episodes have a tendency
to be some of the most
meta some of the most self-referential
some of the most
nudging to the audience
type of material and i actually find
that to be true in the dramas in the
sci-fi fantasy definitely in the sitcoms
they they get
a little looser again even the more
serious stuff sort of usually
feeling a little
more playful
with how they go about things
i also find it interesting that it's not
uncommon for the only episode of a show
to ever feature snow is going to be a
christmas episode
as if winter doesn't last for months
i have nowhere else to put that tidbit
but it kind of bugs me
i don't know when snow became
exclusively christmas's domain
because as someone who lives in vermont
and and winter is
a long-winded season
yeah no
santa does not own snow
let it snow and winter wonderland should
not be labeled as christmas songs
they're just
winter songs winter lasts longer than
december
tangent
sorry
couldn't help myself
that's one of the that's one of the
weird quirks that
bugs me now some shows actually managed
to hang a lampshade on that uh buffy did
it's set in california they shouldn't be
having snow they point that out uh
doctor who it actually was a running
thing for a while that they weren't
getting real snow it was like
disintegrating stuff in the atmosphere
or the doctor caused it artificially or
something so like they almost made a
running gag out of the fact that yeah
there's snow but it's not actually snow
that is snowing i love snow
but i think
in general what i really admire
about the christmas episode i say this
is someone who
has
you know engaged with christmas my
entire life
but never really as a religious thing
for me it's a secular holiday i know for
some people it is deeply religious it's
not for me it never has been and i can't
imagine it ever will be
but as someone who has had christmas
throughout my entire life
i do appreciate that
when tv shows do christmas
they feel
some version
of the holiday spirit
whether it be
literally having an episode about
christmas traditions like in a lot of
sitcoms
whether it be
just having a
slightly more festive tone to the
overall thing or even in the case of
those dramas that i mentioned with all
the family bickering still bringing it
to a nice
conclusion is what the vast majority of
them do
and i just
like the fact
that tv as a whole
gets into the spirit of the holiday
except for black mirror because that
episode of that show [ __ ] broke me
anyways
what is your favorite
christmas episode of a tv
show why do you love it
what about it
speaks to you i don't know if i actually
have an answer for myself because
ironically enough given how i opened
this whole thing and pointed out the
difference between a christmas special
and an episode of a tv show it's
specials that are kind of the backbone
of my christmas viewing you know the
animated how the grinch stole christmas
charlie brown garfield christmas which
is a special
the his regular tv show didn't come out
until later but i suppose if i were to
pick one
uh would actually be that first futurama
one where robot sandal was introduced
come on everybody if you don't believe
in him he can't hurt you oh god the pain
they did some good stuff with him later
but
i i really do i really do
get a kick out of that one and it's one
of the ones i will actually go out of my
way to watch during the season
but whatever it is for you drop
something down in the comments let's
talk about it
thank you so much for your time
like share subscribe help me out i got a
patreon if you're feeling particularly
generous tis the season
don't worry about it though
because at the end of the day
you are the council
i'm just running the meetings this is
the last meeting of 2021
and i will see you
in 2022
be well
be safe
be kind you are beautiful
you are
valid and you are loved
have a good one
[Music]
none of this would have been possible
without my supporters over on patreon in
particular i want to thank robin powell
raven mcbain tracy scrabbit vincent paul
bartolucci robin moore and shayla
gourley if you'd like to hear me
possibly mispronounce your name maybe
consider looking at the reward tears
over on the patreon
but either way don't worry about it too
much
take care of yourself
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
um
[Music]